Here's another example of when
tag templates could come in
handy. It's when you're trying
to add an abbreviation tag to a
sentence. I've got this
dictionary object right here
where HTML, CSS and JS, and it
just shows what they actually
mean. Now if I go down here and
make a sentence about myself,
and say, "hello, my name is..."
I want to pop in the first, and
I want to pop in the last, and, "
I love to code." Now I don't
have variables for HTML, CSS and
JS. What you can do to make them
interpolated is just pass a
string, "HTML, CSS and JS." Now
just because I pass in a string
and not a variable, they are
still going to show up when we
have that tag template. I am
going to just pop this into...
I've got this bio right here.
I'm going to show you another
way. Instead of just popping it
right into the body, let's show
you how I might create an
element. I'm going to say const
bio = query selector. Going to
create a paragraph element, and
I'm going to set the inside of
that paragraph to be the
sentence. Append it. Now we
go to our HTML here, say, "hello
my name is Wes Boss. I love to
code HTML, CSS and JS." Now, how
do we get it so that when I
hover any of these variables, if
there is a dictionary item for
that variable or for that thing
that was passed in, that it will
then show up? That's where we
can get a tag template. I'm
going to make a function here
called "add abbreviations." I
copy paste it there, so I do not
know how to spell abbreviation.
In this, so it's going to be a
little bit different than the
last one that we did. I want to
make a new array of, not just of
values, because the values are
going to give me "Wes," "Boss," "
HTML," "CSS," and "JS." I
want an array of values that, if
there's an abbreviation, I want
them wrapped in an APBR tag.
What I'm going to say is const
abbreviated. I'm going to take
the regular values and map over
them, and return a new array of
the values. We'll say for each
value...now we're going to check
if there is a value in the
dictionary. We'll say if the
dictionary has an item for that
specific value, so if there's a
value of "Wes," is there's going
to be a value of "Wes?" No,
there's not. It's just going to
skip over that. Is there a value
of "HTML?" If the dictionary has
an "HTML" key, oh yes there is,
there is one. We're just using a
variable there. If that is
true then, we are going to
return the abbreviation tag,
which is "APBR," and the title
of that abbreviation tag is
going to be the dictionary item
with that key of "HTML, CSS or
JS." Then inside of the
abbreviation tag, we are going
to return the value there. What
that's going to give us if we
console.log the abbreviated
values here, and we take that
tag template, pop it on to here.
You'll see we get undefined,
undefined. Why do we get
undefined, undefined? That's Wes
and Boss, what I forgot to do
here. Otherwise, we just want to
return the value. If it's not in
the dictionary, it's just a
regular variable. We're going to
skip over that, but we still
need to return it into the
actual variable there. Here we
go. "Wes Boss." Now each of
our values array is now
abbreviation tags that have been
created for us, cool. Now we're
not working with the values or
any more. We're going to be
working with this new
abbreviated tag. Then we can
take our strings array and start
to piece it together. Last time
I did this one, where I said let
string = empty string and that
might be comfortable for you.
If you would rather use a reduce
function, I'm going to show you
how to do that. From this
abbreviation function, we are
going to return strings.reduce().
The way that reduce works is
that it will loop over each one,
and build the string as we go.
It has that all inside of the
function. We don't have to say
this like let str = outside of
the function. The whole thing
is nice and tidy inside of a
single reduce function. Reduce
takes two things. It takes the
function, and it takes what you
start with. We're going to start
with an empty string, and then
the actual function that we want
to run is going to be an
anonymous function, which gives
us sentence, which is going to
be whatever the previous one was.
The first one it's going to be a
blank string. It's going to give
us the actual string and the
index for that one. I'm going to
use an error function with a
block here. From that we return.
We're just going to build this
entire thing together. We want
to take the existing sentence.
This is going to be whatever it
was from the last iteration.
We are going to tack on the
string. Notice how I'm not doing
a space here, because the spaces
that are in the string will
actually come along in the
string itself. We don't need a
space there. Then we want to
tack on the abbreviated, because
we have this array here. Square
bracket "I" or nothing, just
that little trick that we did
earlier there. What that does
is -- I think now we should take
a look. "String is not defined."
Uh, oh, where is that our string, "
S." strings that reduce? There
we go. "Hello my name is Wes
Boss. I love to code HTML,"
hover over, "CSS and JS." I
inspect that. Now our string
here has been created with
abbreviation tag. That's a
great example of when you might
want to use it. You just have to
tack on this add abbreviation
and it's going to externally go
and look up your dictionary, as
well as, do all of this messy
function right here. You just
have to tack this one on in
front of any time that you use
it.